zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
millionen bahnkunden blicken gebannt
nach frankfurt oder haben gebannt
dorthin geblickt wo das arbeitsgericht
entschieden hat und jetzt auch geurteilt
hat der bahnstreik ist rechtens und darf
fortgesetzt werden was bedeutet das
jetzt es wird erstmal weiter gestreikt
davon ist auszugehen aber wird die bahn
jetzt der gdl auch noch mehr
entgegenkommen zum beispiel darüber
sprechen wir jetzt hier in der sendung
mit claus weselsky dem
bundesvorsitzenden der gewerkschaft
deutscher lokomotivführer gdl mit anja
bröker der sprecherin der deutschen bahn
mit zdf korrespondent peter theisen und
mit unserem rechtsexperten felix
zimmermann und wir freuen uns wenn sie
ihre fragen und kommentare zu diesem
thema mit in die sendung einbringen und
uns schreiben wie immer in die
kommentare oder an die eingeblendete e
mail adresse wenn sie die app nutzen wir
beginnen mit unseren kollegen vor ort
der die verhandlung begleitet hat peter
theißen guten namen wie kam das gericht
zu diesem urteil
ja das gericht hat ganz eindeutig
geurteilt hat abgewiesen die forderung
der bahn diesen streiks sofort zu
beenden das war das was die bahn wollte
es ging dabei auch um das so genannte
tarif einheits gesetz darauf beruft sich
die bahn immer wieder sie sagt
eigentlich wollen wir nur mit der
gewerkschaft verhandeln die in einem
bestimmten bereich die meisten
mitglieder hat das hat das gericht
zurückgewiesen das gericht kann man
sagen hat die position der gewerkschaft
gdl recht eindeutig gestärkt es hält
diesen streik für verhältnismäßig und
rechtmäßig dann sprechen wir gleich mit
dem gdl-vorsitzenden darüber inwiefern
er sich gestärkt sieht dankeschön peter
theißen und schauen aber erst noch mal
mit christian folgt zusammen auf die
forderungen die die gdl in diesem
tarifkonflikt aufgestellt hat
im tarifkonflikt zwischen bahn und
lokführer gewerkschaft gdl ist bisher
keine einigung in sicht die gdl fordert
insgesamt 3,2 prozent mehr geld 1,4
prozent schon in diesem jahr den rest
2022 bei einer laufzeit von insgesamt 28
monaten außerdem will die gewerkschaft
eine corona prämie von 600 euro die noch
in diesem jahr bezahlt werden soll und
die betriebsrente soll beibehalten
werden das neue angebot der bahn ist
nicht weit davon weg auch die bahn
bietet insgesamt 3,2 prozent mehr geld
aber erst ab januar beziehungsweise ab
2023 und mit einer längeren laufzeit von
insgesamt 36 monaten auch die bahn
bietet mittlerweile eine corona prämie
von 400 bis 600 euro je nach
entgeltgruppe
tja und jetzt ist er uns zugeschaltet
gdl chef claus weselsky harry selbst wie
zufrieden sind sie mit diesem urteil
und ich bin erleichtert und froh darüber
dass deutsches gericht bestätigt hat
dass unsere streiks rechtmäßig zulässig
und auch verhältnismäßig sind insoweit
bin ich froh allerdings wäre das
vielleicht nicht lange denn nach meiner
information hat die deutsche bahn ag
bereits berufung gegen das
erstinstanzliche urteil eingelegt und
deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich morgen
die nächste verhandlung vor dem
landesarbeitsgericht hessen geben
brechen sie den streik ab so wie es die
gdl 2014 2015 in der auseinandersetzung
schon mal gemacht hat
ich habe auf die frage gewartet und ich
nehme wahr dass sie wie viele andere
menschen in diesem land auch hier in die
wiederholung der geschichte sind und
feststellen dass 2014/15 genau derselbe
film abgelaufen ist und die bahn genauso
lange gezögert hat und der konflikt ewig
und drei tage gegen das sind diesmal
schneller unterwegs und auch härter und
ich möchte an der stelle keine hoffnung
wecken wir brechen einen streik ab wenn
wir ein verhandlungsfähiges angebot
bekommen und in verhandlungen eintreten
wir müssen nicht offiziell verhandeln
man kann genauso gut während einer
arbeitskampfmaßnahme im hintergrund
verhandeln und erlebnisse erzählen das
was wir damals gemacht haben waren die
große erleichterung darüber dass wir in
zwei instanzen gewonnen haben ich weiß
nicht wie das magische urteil ausgeht
ich möchte an der
das kann niemand vorwegnehmen und
deswegen werde ich auch den ausführungen
machen wie lange der streik geht wir
haben gerade gesehen sie sind ja
eigentlich gar nicht so weit auseinander
sind sie denn bereit zu verhandeln
wir sind jederzeit bereit zu verhandeln
die deutsche bahn ag hatte in ihrem
angebot
erneut reingeschrieben das sind nur zu
verhandlungen bereit sind wenn wir den
streik abbrechen das werden wir nicht
tun weil wir uns keine bedingungen
stellen lassen von der anderen seite die
andere seite hat seit monaten die
menschen in diesem land verschaukelt und
von daher sehen wir keinen grund uns auf
etwas einzulassen was so enden kann dass
wir verhandeln verhandeln und keinen
millimeter weiter kommen wir haben die
verhandlungen am see juni abgebrochen
und von daher bleiben wir auch auf dem
grundsatz wir treten den verhandlungen
ein wenn ordnungsgemäßer angebote
vorlegen und vor allen dingen eins
möchte ich korrigieren bei ihrer
darstellung dass sieht alles sehr
ähnlich aus dass sich auch geschickt
gemacht aber ob sie 36 monate laufzeit
haben oder 28 ist ein gewaltiger
unterschied was den wert des
tarifvertrags betrifft und der nucleus
in der derzeitigen auseinandersetzung
sind tarifverträge für alle unsere
mitglieder grundgesetzlich geschützten
koalitionsfreiheit
werden wir nicht ab bedingen in dieser
auseinandersetzung
wir werden nichts tun was unrecht ist
und wir werden in unserer gewerkschaft
keine mitglieder erster und zweiter
klasse haben das ist eine der
perry selbst geht diese sendung lebt
auch von den zuschauer kommentaren einen
möchte ich gerne an der stelle weiter
geben er will federer schreibt über
youtube gdl macht alles richtig weiter
so dass es eine stimme es gibt aber
natürlich auch viel gegenwind vor allem
von den bahnkunden die sich jetzt gerade
wo noch ferien sind oder wo in vielen
orten schon der schulbeginn wieder
gestartet ist fragen warum muss die bahn
jetzt wie sie gerade die die gdl wie sie
gerade sagen härter noch streiken fünf
tage lang haben sie keine angst dass sie
den rückhalt in der bevölkerung
verlieren
es gibt sicherlich niemanden der über
einen streik im eisenbahnsystem
begeisterung entfacht das ist uns
vollkommen klar aber ich habe an der
stelle immer die klare botschaft
gebracht es gibt überhaupt keine zeit
weder über ein jahr gesehen noch
innerhalb eines tages wir könnten nach
zwischen 12 und halb drei steigen uns
würde trotzdem noch jemand getroffen
werden weil das eisenbahnsystem stark
frequentiert ist der arbeitskampf ist
unser letztes mittel zudem haben wir
gegriffen weil wir in den verhandlungen
gescheitert sind weil wir ein
arbeitgeber vor uns sitzen haben der
einerseits der gdl das deg zur anwendung
bringt gegen die gdl damit leben das
kann er das gesetz ist da aber der uns
andererseits versucht daran zu hindern
die mehrheit in den betrieben für unsere
tarifverträge zu gewinnen und an der
stelle mit der mehrheit der mitglieder
unsere tarifverträge in die zukunft
hinein zu sichern und das ist ein
eingriff in die grundrechte unserer
mitglieder und auch in unsere
grundrechte ich frage nochmal aus
kundensicht sozusagen wie gesagt kinder
die jetzt zur schule fahren großeltern
die ihre enkel besuchen wollen die
stress kriegen haben sie mitleid mit dem
mitleid darf man an der stelle zu nicht
zum ausdruck bringen wir haben bedauern
wir wissen dass viele menschen betroffen
sind wir wissen aber auch dass sie
alternativen greifen und spitz hier
einfach nicht so zu tun als würde dieses
ganze land nur auf einem einzigen
verkehrssysteme existieren das eisenbahn
heißt es gibt andere verkehrssysteme und
die menschen sind klug wenn sie auf
leipziger hauptbahnhof ich heute früh
war gehen das sehen sie kaum menschen
das sensible züge und das heißt im
umkehrschluss die menschen haben sich
darauf eingerichtet wobei es natürlich
gut ist für die lokführer wenn die
menschen mit der bahn fahren da sind wir
uns nützen wir auch ins wahrscheinlich
eigentlich am ende eine frage hätte ich
noch
alexander druck und hat ihnen heute
vorgeworfen einen egotrip zu fahren geht
es ihnen um höhere löhne geht es ihnen
um die existenz der gdl oder geht es in
um sich selbst
auch das wiederholt sich in dieser
geschichte was ich nicht alles schon
genannt wurden bin ich bin der
vorsitzende einer gewerkschaft die in
den letzten 14 monaten 4000 neue
mitglieder in ihren begrüßen konnte so
schlecht kann ich nicht sein und meine
organisation in 4000 eisenbahnerinnen
und eisenbahner bei uns eintreten weil
sie in uns die richtige
interessenvertretung erster punkt
zweiter punkt es ist nie die sache eines
einzelnen mannes ich streike nicht dass
das auch mal zur kenntnis nehmen ich bin
hier schwer arbeiten aber jede jede
streikmaßnahmen bisschen mehr als 10.000
unserer mitglieder 10.000 arbeitnehmer
dieses konzerns sind im streik auf
stellwerken in werkstatt aufzügen
entschieden und an der stelle sage ich
einfach mal es ist an der zeit dass die
beteiligten auch alle verstehen ich
ergänzen mitarbeiter gegen ein
management das in der umverteilung von
unten nach oben wohnen und sie wehren
sich dagegen dass sich das management
die taschen füllt und den mitarbeitern
die betriebsrente weggenommen wird das
ist etwas was eine ureigenste aufgabe
von gewerkschaften ist und wer das sind
auges zulässt hat noch mein auf nach
meinem dafürhalten und dem meiner
mitglieder denn am gewerkschaft nicht
verdient ich möchte gern noch eine
zuschauerfrage weitergeben nadal ives
nlp schreibt auch über youtube schön die
wenigen züge rand voll packen gute
corona maßnahme dieser streik kommt
mitten in der pandemie ist das
verantwortungslos
das ist es nicht sie wissen dass
gutachterlich von der charité und noch
ein zweiter unternehmen festgestellt
wurden ist das kein erhöhtes
ansteckungsrisiko in den zügen besteht
das ist einerseits zum schutz unserer
kolleginnen und kollegen die in den
zügen unterwegs sind andererseits auch
zum schutz der reisenden absichtlich
untersucht wurden und wir sollten uns
bitte an fakten orientieren und nicht an
der an der maßnahme darf man in volle
züge einsteigen oder nicht wenn sie wie
ich 70.000 kilometer im jahr mit
eisenbahn unterwegs sind als dienstreise
dann erleben sie jetzt nie bloß unter
streikmaßnahmen sondern an wochenenden
an spitzentagen erleben sie volle züge
und sie erleben bei den vielen
baumaßnahmen übervolle reisebusse die im
schienenersatzverkehr unterwegs sind
einfach niemand danach aber beim streik
uns dass anzudichten halte ich gelinde
ausgedrückt für unfair und vor allen
dingen auch für einseitig denn für in
streik oder in streit gibt es immer zwei
und die gdl ist eine partei davon
versprochen allerletzte frage sie sind
glaube ich die älteste deutsche
gewerkschaft sie haben eine gut gefüllte
streikkasse
sie haben angedroht wenn sie wollten
könnten sie so lange streiken bis die
streikkasse leer ist auf was müssen wir
uns einstellen
erst mal bitte schön in der hoffnung auf
ein zur vernunft gerufen ist vom
eigentümer gerufenes management der db
ag sollten wir uns darauf einstellen
dass ist die leichte letzte
arbeitskampfmaßnahme ist vorausgesetzt
von morgen ein weiteres urteil zu
unseren gunsten wird der arbeitskampf
beendet so wie geplant und anschließend
ist die frage eines weiteren
arbeitskampfes eindeutig beim management
angesiedelt sie haben vor uns gesagt was
unsere kolleginnen und kollegen am
liebsten machen am liebsten vom
lokführer züge pünktlich durch dieses
land begleiten zugbegleitung gastronomen
zufriedene fahrgäste in pünktlichen und
zuverlässigen zügen durch dieses land
vor dienstleiter stellt mit vergnügen
weichen und gewährleisten einen sicheren
und pünktlichen eisenbahnverkehr für
güter und personenzüge das ist die
profession die eisenbahnerinnen und
eisenbahner haben und das was wir in der
vergangenheit erleben durften dass die
eisenbahn wetter pünktlich noch
zuverlässig ist weder was mit der gdl
noch mit streik zu tun sondern mit
unfähigkeit eines managements das
eisenbahn organisieren langsam verlernt
hat da hat einer noch lange nicht fertig
vielen dank dass wir selbst für dieses
statement an diesem abend dankeschön
nach frankfurt und wir machen hier im
studio weiter mit unserem rechtsexperten
felix zimmermann felix wenn man sich
gerichtsentscheide anguckt über
urteile streiks kurzfristig zu beenden
dann sieht man gerichte urteilen sehr
selten dass streiks kurzfristig beendet
werden müssen auch in diesem fall woran
liegt das also erst mal haben wir eben
in deutschland diese koalitionsfreiheit
das ist ein grundrecht in artikel 9 des
grundgesetzes darf streik organisationen
geben dürfen streiten und da gibt es
eben nur ganz enge ausnahmen wir stellen
uns natürlich immer so vor es gibt
diesen grundsatz der verhältnismäßigkeit
ein streik muss verhältnismäßig sein
aber das betrifft leider nicht die
verhältnismäßigkeit für die bürgerinnen
und bürger die genervt sind die stress
haben oder auch die korona geschichte
sondern ist betrifft eben wirklich
betriebsinterner also verhältnismäßig
ist ein streik dann wenn zum beispiel
vorher auch verhandelt wurde das tat
bemühungen gab es unterschiedliche
einfach streiken wenn man vorher nicht
irgendwie mal versucht hat eine lösung
zu finden das geht es um das bin ich
genau das geht zum beispiel nicht oder
es gibt die friedenspflicht und darf
halt nicht zum beispiel gegen einen
laufenden tarifvertrag etwas neues
verhandeln wollen das gibt es auch nicht
was man eben auch nicht machen kann in
deutschland ist es ein ziel anzuvisieren
was überhaupt nicht in einem
tarifvertrag regelbar ist dann kannst du
wahrscheinlich sagen wir streiken jetzt
mal für höhere renten dass die politik
sich das gibt es in frankreich denkt ja
immer diesen generalstreik da gibt es
politische streit das ist bei uns auch
nicht möglich also es gibt gewisse
grenzen aber die korona pandemie zum
beispiel ist da keine grenze und wenn
die züge übervoll sind weil jetzt eben
sich viele rein drängen und da ist da
womöglich doch eben schaden geben kann
mehr schaden seitige sohn den
menschenverstand das ist der fall ist
dann ist es leider kein
erwägungsgrund der seine rolle spielt
leider aus der sich der bahn konnten
aber auf der anderen seite muss man
natürlich sehen ist es eben ein
grundrecht man will für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen streiten und
offensichtlich hat das gericht eben hier
auch nicht gesagt dass sachfremde
erwägungen gibt sondern dass der streik
geben in ordnung geht die voraussetzung
erfüllt also nur weil manche sagen herr
weselsky führt einen machtkampf mit der
bahn und deshalb findet dieser streik
statt das wäre ein politischer grund das
wäre kein grund für diesen streik aber
das gericht hat nicht erkannt dass das
der fall ist sondern hat gesagt nein die
gründe sind in ordnung es geht um tarife
löhne alles was man regeln kann mit
tarifverhandlungen also darf weiter
gestreikt absolut aber das ist natürlich
dann auch bewiesen werden vor gericht
wie können ja nicht in die köpfe genau
hinein schauen was die motivation ist
die vielleicht dahinter steckt hinter
einem arbeitskampf aber wenn das gericht
jetzt zu dem schluss gekommen wäre da
verstecken sich sachfremde motive hinter
vermeintlichen lohnforderungen zum
beispiel dann hätte es zum beispiel den
streik kippen können aber zu dieser
erkenntnis ist das gericht nicht
gelangt so dass man bis solange ihm
davon ausgehen muss dass vielleicht ist
ein machtkampf auf der unteren ebene
über die tarifeinheit gesetz über die
partner gewerkschaft und
konkurrenzgewerkschaft besser gesagt
aber das hat das gericht eben nicht so
gesehen dass
tarifeinheit gesetz kannst du erklären
was es damit auf sich hat denn das rührt
er an den kern dieses konflikts zwischen
gdl und der bahn ja das wurde
verabschiedet eigentlich um solche
maßnahmen zu verhindern führt aber
irgendwie zum gegenteil jedenfalls im
sektor bahn es ist so dass noch diesen
tarif einheits gesetz nur die
gewerkschaft einen tarifvertrag
abschließen kann die die mehrheit hat
der mitglieder jetzt steht man aber
nicht alle zusammen in gesamtdeutschland
wer hat mehr mitglieder die eine
gewerkschaft wird die andere sondern
schaut sich die einzelnen betriebe an
also muss immer unterscheiden juristisch
es gibt die bahn das ist ein unternehmen
aber es gibt verschiedene einheiten
betriebe und je mehr jemand sich jeden
einzelnen
und wenn da im betrieb die gewerkschaft
evg die mehrheit hat und im betrieb
geben jetzt die gelöschten weselsky dann
darf die eine gewerkschaft für den
bereich und die anderen andere bereich
tarifverträge abschließen das führt
natürlich gerade erst im wettbewerb
innerhalb der betriebe um mitglieder und
da könnte es natürlich schon sein dass
da diejenige werkstoff die mit power
auftritt und ordentlich krach macht ja
dass die vielleicht sich dadurch erhofft
mitglieder zu erwerben um die an der
gesellschaft einer anderen gewerkschaft
sozusagen zuvorzukommen und besser zu
werden und mehr macht zu bekommen und
dadurch wiederum mehr mitglieder also
dieser konkurrenzkampf ist ja so ein
bisschen das problem
in anderen bereichen ja wo im grunde in
jedem betrieb die organisation so ist
dass es dann quasi eine haupt
gewerkschaft gibt führt das vielleicht
dazu dass kleine gewerkschaften nicht
mehr so viel macht haben und nicht mehr
so viel in der hand haben wie zb
fluggesellschaften da ist alles
irgendwie so da gibt es piloten aber die
sind nämlich in der mehrheit ja aber bei
seinen betrieb wieder mit der bahn wo es
eben ganz verschiedene
mehrheitsverhältnisse gibt da ist ihm
der konkurrenzkampf wird entfacht
das gesetz ist ja noch gar nicht so alt
aber die grünen wollen es wieder
abschaffen aus den gerade von dir
genannten gründen weil eben diese
konkurrenzsituation entsteht was glaubst
du ist das nur bei der bahn so weil sich
eben die fronten zwischen diesen beiden
gewerkschaften so verhärtet haben oder
sorgt auch das tarif ein neues gesetz in
anderen bereichen für für probleme und
müsste man da grundsätzlich was regeln
also wenn man sich das zuerst betrachtet
sie sich schon probleme haben habe ich
ja gesagt artikel 9 die
koalitionsfreiheit ist darf also
gewerkschaften geben und
verfassungsrechtlich ist es ja schon ein
problem wenn dann die gewerkschaften
auch wenn sie klein sind plötzlich keine
tarifverträge mehr abschließen können
aber das wurde bislang also rechtlich
nicht als problematisch angesehen führt
aber eben in bestimmten bereichen dazu
dass konkurrenz entsteht in anderen
bereichen vielleicht nicht ja wo es ein
betrieb gebunden und immer klar die
gewerkschaft
die mehrheit hat und die anderen kleinen
gewerkschaften eher unter ferner liefen
laufen dann haben die natürlich weniger
macht aber hier bei der bahn es ist eben
so dass es da so ein kopf an kopf rennen
gibt teilweise in manchen betrieben die
eine gewerkschaft hinaus fordern die
anderen und da ist eben der
konkurrenzkampf da und da sollten wir
vielleicht doch noch mal drüber schauen
ob das so sinnvoll ist auch natürlich
für die jeweiligen mitarbeitenden der
bahn weil bei denen ist dann immer so
völlig zufällig in welchem betrieb
arbeite ich habe ich vielleicht die
vergünstigung weil da die gewerkschaft
an das gute für mich heraus gehandelt
hat aber dafür fahren andere dinge weg
die ich hätte wenn ich in einem anderen
betrieb in einer anderen stadt wir haben
sie so richtig unter gleichheits
gesichtpunkten sich auch nicht so
richtig sind wollen ich würde gern zwei
ganz zuschauer nahe juristische fragen
stellen die eine ist
der zahlt keine stornokosten wenn ich
nicht rechtzeitig ans ziel komme seit
einem jahr gebucht stornieren geht so
kurzfristig nicht erstattet dass dann
die reiserücktrittversicherung
das muss ich auf ein band also wenn ich
wirklich verstehe jurist turin schmidt
fragt das über youtube herr schmidt das
scheint sich auf ein bahnticket zu
beziehen was sie gebucht haben und sie
haben jetzt ein problem weil gestreikt
wird ich hoffe wir haben das richtig ich
glaube die reiserücktrittsversicherung
wird er hat er nicht in anspruch nehmen
weil die bahn ja da sehr kulant ist was
diese dinge angeht und wenn der zug
ausfällt man auch den vollen fahrpreis
in der regel zurück bekommt ok andere
frage lukas schreibt auch über youtube
ist der nächste schritt eine woche lang
zu streiken oder länger das hat herr
weselsky ja recht kämpferisch also zwar
nicht beantwortet aber klar es könnte
sein dass dann auch mehr streiks auf uns
zukommen aber gibt es eigentlich eine
höchstdauer von streikte also darf darf
man maximal fünf tage streiken oder kann
die bahn jetzt sagen wir streiken hat
infinitum oder bis erste dezember oder
gibt es da eine gesetzliche regeln um
die gesetzliche regelung gibt es nicht
aber diese zu dieser verhältnismäßigkeit
gehört auch der streit muss
verhältnismäßig sein gehört auch dass
man den eigenen das eigene unternehmen
nicht ökonomisch ruinieren darf ja
sozusagen eine voraussetzung wo dann
irgendwann die gericht aussagen wird
also das geht jetzt dann soweit also
wenn wir sagen würden drei vier monate
steigen wir durch weil die streikkasse
so voll ist ich weiß nicht ob diese voll
wäre das würde dann irgendwann eben an
die grenzen kommen weil das dann darauf
abzielt zu ökonomisch zu
einer fertig zu machen ein bis zwei
wochen wären dann spreche ich jetzt aus
juristischer sicht erst mal auf den
ersten blick nichts dagegen ich würde
sagen dass ein bis zwei wochen müssen
sich jetzt die frage stellen würde das
die bahn ruinieren können um die würde
man wahrscheinlich verneinen
so dass das versteck nicht mittel ja
okay noch eine frage ich habe gelesen
dass in japan busfahrer gestreikt haben
indem sie nicht zulasten der kunden
gestreikt haben soll die lasten des
unternehmens indem sie nicht zu hause
geblieben sind sondern sie sind bus
gefahren haben die leute mit verlassen
haben aber keine tickets kassiert das
heißt sie haben die leute umsonst fahren
lassen und damit gestreikt indem sie das
unternehmen geschädigt haben wäre das
wenn man einen teil seiner arbeit
erfüllt denn gefahren sind sie ja einen
anderen aber nicht nämlich das kassieren
wenn man das in deutschland auch machen
würde wäre das möglich auch auf diese
art in deutschland zu streiken das heißt
alle können fröhlich bahnfahren
gestreikt wird trotzdem und der
geschädigte ist die bahn geht das so
schöne idee
müsste man jetzt ausführlich prüfen
meine erste ansicht dazu wäre nein es
geht nicht ja also erstmal würde man
sich da auch wirklich arbeit es gibt das
recht zu streiken aber es gibt nicht das
recht an der arbeit schlecht zu machen
unserer guten arbeit gehört nun mal auch
das abkassieren
wenn es notwendig ist also dass ich
glaube ich bei uns nicht möglich
ich gucke hier gerade mal in die
kommentare evers meyer schreibt per e
mail
es keine frage sind einfach nur ein paar
eindrücke von von bahn kundinnen und
kunden und da gibt es natürlich auch
sehr leid geprüfte pendler oder reisende
evers meyer schreibt ich wollte morgen
nach anderthalb jahren mit meinen beiden
kindern das erste mal wieder verreisen
nach oberfranken es ist eine frechheit
eine ungerechtigkeit
davon gibt es viele stimmen
denn natürlich sind es die kundinnen und
kunden die am ende genau diese probleme
haben und dann am bahnhof stehen und die
züge fahren dich oder die züge sind voll
noch eine e-mail haben wir bekommen das
geht an herrn weselsky
ohne absender ich würde sehr gern wissen
mit welcher berechtigung dieser mensch
sein ego kampf auf meinem rücken
austrägt ich bin rentner muss noch was
dazu verdienen um mir ein wenig leisten
zu können dafür muss ich mit der s bahn
fahren und kann nicht wie dieser herr
auf ein auto zurückgreifen auch ich
musste eine nullrunde hinnehmen obwohl
ich sicher die rente von mindestens fünf
monaten zusammen legen muss um auf das
einkommen dieses mannes zu kommen
schämen sie sich
das ist ein
natürlich immer die perspektive die
natürlich so ein bisschen auch aufgebaut
wird
die man so als feindbild aufzubauen aber
da muss man schon recht geben das ist ja
nicht er der jetzt hier die fehlende
hand hat sondern eben tausende
mitarbeiter die sagen diese blumen
bedingungen gefallen uns nicht ja und
diese 1000 mitarbeiter die wird man auch
nicht so manipulieren können das ist ihr
hauptinteresse ist die gdl weiter zu
stärken das ist jetzt nicht nichts was
die mitarbeitenden mitarbeiter
angestellt interessiert den geht um den
lohn ja so dass man jetzt dieses
feindbild herr schelsky habe ich schon
ein stück weit an der sache vorbei geht
war das ja nicht aus jux und tollerei
macht und dahinter eben viele viele
tausende angestellte lokführer und eben
wie wir gerade gehört haben noch andere
angestellte der bahn städten ja und man
sieht ja auch wenn man in beiträgen bei
uns in ottl nie sieht was die leute an
den bahnhöfen sagen dann ist auch viel
verständnis einmal dann sagen die das
ist zwar jetzt uncool und der zug fährt
nicht und natürlich habe ich ist das
unangenehm aber wenn sie für ihre rechte
kämpfen wollen dann sollen sie das tun
also die stimmen gibt es ja auch ja es
ist immer die frage perspektive
vorletzte woche auch bahn fahren wollte
die ganzen aber jede fahrt von frankfurt
nach hamburg ausgefallen zwei tage da
denkt man dann in der situation mensch
sich dann doch anders als wenn man sich
in die lage der lokführer werden
versetzt die um ihren lohn kämpfen die
gerecht behandelt werden wollen was ihre
perspektive
noch mal zurück zu diesem urteil heute
was verändert das jetzt also die bahn
wird berufung einlegen haben wir gerade
die quelle ist herr weselsky ich habe
selber jetzt noch nicht gelesen aber
die bahn wird wahrscheinlich berufung
hatte sind nun hat es auch angehörige
sprecherin
das heißt es geht jetzt erstmal so
weiter oder oder was passiert jetzt als
nächstes genau also das ist ja nicht so
gericht erlaubt bahnstreik sondern
gericht verbietet beim streik nicht ja
so ist die richtige formulierung und
deswegen aktuell war eine einstweilige
verfügung hat ein schnellverfahren
deswegen heute ja wo der innerhalb von
drei stunden ja hier verhandelt und
entschieden und morgen geht es dann eben
wieder höheren instanz weiter und es
würde den berufung eingelegt und ist
auch morgens schon mit einem urteil zu
rechnen
mal sehen wie das ausfällt
es ist noch mal in richtung ja um eine
service frage sozusagen viele zuschauer
haben nicht das problem mit dem
ticketpreis der der ihnen den sie jetzt
umsonst ausgegeben haben sondern die
kostenerstattung des urlaubs der nicht
angetreten werden kann was ist denn da
wenn ich ein hotel gebucht haben in
südtirol und ich kann da jetzt aus
verschiedenen gründen nicht hin weil der
zug nicht fährt
was mache ich dann mit den hotelkosten
wenn ich den studieren muss weil ich
nicht hinkomme weil die bahn streikt ja
das ist natürlich die frage dass das
eigene verschulden weil es besteht ja
immer noch die möglichkeit ein auto
anzumieten na ja das ist ja nicht völlig
unmöglich irgendwo anders hin zu kommen
und auch aus die muss es mir leisten
können muss sich leisten können das auto
bezahlt das ist richtig aber für den
schadensersatz wurde sitzt erstmal ist
die erste sache man kann irgendwie hin
kommen und zweitens ist auch die andere
frage wenn man mit der bahn einen
vertrag abschließen beförderungsvertrag
impliziert dass er nicht ordentlich
dahin damit du das und das machen kannst
ja stellen sie sich mal vor das hätte
ich mir vor als würde ein es geht darum
einen millionengewinn oder einen
millionenvertrag und der wird nicht
zustande kommt nicht zustande weil
jemand den zug weil der zug verspätung
hat dann kann man die bahn auch nicht
dafür in anspruch nehmen dass der
millionen vertrag ist nicht
unterschrieben wurde das ist quasi nicht
innerhalb der leistung mit enthalten was
man vor ort machen kann so dass da in
der regel schadensersatz für sowas eben
auch ausfällt
hat man dann leider pech gehabt
wahrscheinlich nicht die antwort die
viele zu hause werden wollten könnte man
denn das auto wenn man sich ein
leihwagen bieten mussten bezahlt einem
dass irgendjemand
also es gibt ja wenn man wenn es eine
verspätung gibt es gibt ja manchmal die
möglichkeit ein taxi zu nehmen auf
kosten der bahn aber auch nur begrenzt
auf bestimmte kilometer dass irgendwann
die die schranken leider gesetzt das
würde also wenn ich jetzt nicht
rechtzeitig zur arbeit käme und ich
brauche ein taxi das könnte ich morgen
früh in diesem fall wenn das meer
passiert ja im fall der verspätung wenn
der zug von vornherein man weiß es ja
auch angekommen ich würde zu von
vornherein nicht fährt muss man sich
darauf nicht berufen können in der regel
muss man sich über jeden fall natürlich
einzeln einzelnen angucken wir haben die
position der bahn schon mehrfach
angesprochen in der sendung und hatten
uns eigentlich auf anja bröker gefreut
die sprecherin der bahn die jetzt aber
leider aus termingründen weil es so spät
geworden ist nicht live in der sendung
sein kann aber wir haben ihr statement
und da haben wir jetzt mal ein wir haben
den antrag auf erlass einer
einstweiligen verfügung gestellt um
unseren kundinnen und kunden
um sie zu bewahren vor diesen dritten
völlig unnötigen gdl-streik die gdl hat
jedem schritt den wir auf sie zugegangen
sind mit blockade quittiert wir haben
bereits jetzt materielle forderungen der
gdl erfüllt dennoch beharrt sie auf
diesem streik und dieser streik stellt
eine enorme belastung für unsere
kundinnen und kunden in ganz deutschland
da wir waren uns bewusst dass die hürden
in solch einem eilverfahren sehr hoch
sind und auch dass das streikrecht in
deutschland sehr geschützt ist aus gutem
grund
dennoch sehen wir es als unsere
verantwortung auch im interesse unserer
kundinnen und kunden nichts unversucht
zu lassen um eben diesen streit zu
beenden
im übrigen hat auch das gericht kritisch
selbst sich mit der rechtsmäßigkeit des
der gdl-forderungen in verschiedenen
punkten befasst das kritisch diskutiert
zum beispiel mit der frage ob die gdl
in wirklichkeit gegen das tarif einheits
gesetz also das bedeutet ein
tarifvertrag je betrieb wirklich
unzulässig schreibt mit dieser frage hat
sich das gericht befasst
das urteil ist ergangen wir werden
deshalb in die zweite instanz gehen und
das heutige urteil vor dem hessischen
landesarbeitsgericht überprüfen lassen
tja so weit anja bröker an dieser stelle
vielen dank felix zimmermann für die
juristische expertise
und nochmal zu peter theißen nach
frankfurt peter ich hätte anja bröker
gerne gefragt bald ist der
bundestagswahl ob man denn bei der bahn
jetzt damit rechnet dass der bund so
viel druck auf die bahn ausgeübt dass
sie der gdl doch nochmal entgegenkommt
kannst du diese frage vielleicht
beantworten
wie kann ich natürlich auch nicht
beantworten die ganz sieht ganz danach
aus dass wir uns tatsächlich auch diesen
streik als bahnkunden auch weiter
einstellen müssen herr bisky hat ja auch
gesagt der letzte große streik 2015 er
hat auch am stück schon einmal 100
stunden gedauert über 100 stunden der
jetzige würde 120 stunden erst mal
dauern wenn er wie geplant verläuft und
man hat ja gespürt auch bei ihrem
gespräch mit herrn weselsky dass die gdl
nicht willens ist vorher einzuknicken
die streikbereitschaft ist groß heute
waren 3300 gdl mitglieder im austand die
allermeisten davon lokführer aber zum
beispiel der 580 gtm glieder die in
borth bistros arbeiten wir müssen morgen
natürlich die entscheidung des
landesarbeitsgerichts abwarten aber
sieht moment ist ihr danach aus dass wir
auch über das wochenende hinweg diesen
mit diesem streik leben müssen die
bahn-sprecherin hat eben noch gesagt
dass versucht wird zumindest 30 prozent
der züge im fernverkehr übers wochenende
rollen zu lassen mal sehen ob das
gelingt
peter wir haben auch alle die lage an
den an den bahnsteigen im blick was
kommt da noch auf die auf die reisenden
zu und wie habt ihr bislang die stimmung
dort erlebt war dass er zustimmung oder
ablehnung
dieser streiks
ich glaube das was auch in vielen
berichten auch so reflektiert wird ist
dass beides natürlich da ist es gibt
menschen die sind verärgert die sind
persönlich sehr stark betroffen weil sie
zu dringenden terminen oder zur
verwandtschaft besuchen die ihnen
wichtig erschienen nicht gekommen sind
ist natürlich verärgert ist vielleicht
dann das verständnis auch geringer aber
wir treffen auch immer wieder sehr viele
menschen die sagen nein die gdl hat
recht man muss der härte zeigen und muss
klare kante gegen die bahn zeigen also
es gibt beide meinungen und wie man
jetzt genau gewichten kann da können
vielleicht umfragen mehr dazu sagen dass
sie jetzt nur persönliche eindrücke ist
aber bald ist es sicherlich vorhanden
ich habe noch eine frage an dich als
reporter du warst ja heute abend auch da
vor ort und hast die protagonisten
sozusagen erlebt jetzt herr weselsky
auch mit dabei martin sailer
personalvorstand deutschen bahn war
nicht dabei also da waren jetzt nicht
zwei kontrahenten in einem raum aber
natürlich zwei parteien wie hast du das
erlebt war das professionell und da
haben anwälte argumente ausgetauscht
oder hat man schon gemerkt dass hier ein
größerer konflikt dahinter steht der
sich weder heute abend noch durch diese
streiks lösen lässt
also ich glaube alle parteien waren sehr
professionell heute es gab ein sehr
spürbares bemühen des richters beide
seiten noch mal zusammen zu bringen er
hat an mehreren stellen beide seiten
dazu gedrängt jetzt geht auch mal einen
anderen raum redet mal miteinander so
weit seit jedoch gar nicht voneinander
entfernt aber dann ist es zu der
situation bekommen zu diesem
teufelskreis in dem wir uns befinden
dass die bahn sagt wir machen erst dann
bessere angebote wenn der streik beendet
wird und die gewerkschaft sagt wir
beenden diesen streik nur wenn besseres
angebot der bahn vorlegt in diesem
teufelskreislauf teufelskreis befinden
wir uns und das hat man dann auch schon
in den zwischentönen gemerkt auch bei
den statements dann die danach von der
bahn und von herrn wir selbst kamen da
war zu spüren
die fronten sind unglaublich hart die
sind ja schon seit 2005 10 seit dieser
großen streikwelle sehr sehr
unversöhnlich sich gegenüber gesessen
immer wieder und das hat sich
fortgesetzt aber ich würde trotzdem
sagen professionell haben beide
gehandelt aber keinen hass spürbar aber
es ist eine ganz klare kante die beide
seiten da sich gegenseitig zeigen
peter theißen es ist spät geworden an
diesem donnerstagabend vielen dank dass
du bei uns in der sendung war es vielen
dank für die berichte vor ort und auch
an sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer vielen dank dass sie
mitgemacht haben das war es von uns für
heute abend bis zum nächsten mal